So I'm getting more and more calls from viewers
and listeners horrified that Donald Trump
is going to cheat his way to reelection later
this year.
And your fears are real and that Donald Trump
will try to cheat.
The question is whether he will succeed.
And what we mean by cheating.
And Heather Digby Parton has a really great
article in Salon about this.
And I'll mention a few of her points and a
few of mine.
She points out that as real as Joe Biden's
leads in the polls right now may well be,
Donald Trump will try to cheat.
And it is going to take everything we have
to keep him from reelection.
Now, what do I mean by cheating?
And I want to be really careful here by cheating.
I mean that failures and vulnerabilities in
the system will lead to Donald Trump maybe
being reelected even when a Biden win would
be the will of the people.
So I'll give you an example of what I mean
by that.
Trump's opposition to vote by mail.
This has been a big thing over the last three
or four weeks, whether we call it literal
cheating, legal cheating or simply suppressing
the will of the people.
Trump trying to win by making it so fewer
people vote is cheating in the sense that
it cheats democracy.
It circumvents the will of the people.
Yesterday I told you about, you know, all
the garbage math that we're going to be hit
by in the coming months where people who don't
even understand growth rates and percentages
are going to quickly be told that we're seeing
the fastest growing economy in history in
the upcoming third quarter, when what we're
seeing is the start of a recovery from the
largest declines of the last hundred years.
So that's not literally cheating, but it is
bamboozling vulnerable people with mathematical
lies.
Another example, Trump has an attorney general
in place,
William Barr.
William Barr is made it clear that he has
absolutely no moral and ethical scruples whatsoever.
He will stop at nothing to help Donald Trump.
Now, you might think, well, hold on a second,
David.
William Barr did recently say he's not going
to prosecute Obama in the fake Obama gate
scandal.
He must realize that that's not okay.
He's doing the ethical thing.
No, all that means is that William Barr recognizes
that in the large scheme of things, a good
prosecuting Barack Obama for the bogus Obama
gate fiasco.
First of all, there's no crime Obama committed.
So what could you really prosecute him for?
He recognizes that it's not the right tool
to use to try to propel Donald Trump to reelection.
Election Day is going to be absolute mayhem
in red states.
You're going to see people show up to vote
and told that
they're not registered due to voter purges.
You're going to see the polling places that
are open.
We don't know how many it's going to be.
It'll depend on the virus.
You're going to see some polling places completely
overloaded in key swing states like Wisconsin
and Pennsylvania and Florida.
You're going to see some so-called patriots
showing up to do security at polling places,
which, of course, will be hugely intimidating
to certain voters.
You're going to see even in states that go
for vote by mail, a concerted effort to disqualify
ballots for bogus reasons.
You're going to see Corona virus probably
keep more Democrats at home than Republicans
because Democrats are more likely to understand
and accept the medical science of corona virus
when Republicans are more likely to ignore
it.
So understand that we have an election coming
up.
And it's not unique in the sense,
but it's exacerbated acutely in this particular
election.
We have an election coming up where one candidate
wants to reduce the number of people that
vote and the other candidate wants as many
people as possible to vote.
Lastly, understand that this is only partially
because of Corona virus.
Even before the Corona virus pandemic in 2017,
there was a poll done asking if Trump suggested
postponing the election.
Would you support it?
More than half of Republicans said they would.
More than half of Republicans before the virus
said we would support postponing the election,
just on Trump's say so.
It's not going to happen this year.
Remember that.
It's up to the states.
There is not a federal election in November.
What we have is an election of a federal government
position, president of the United States done
by 50 individual state elections.
Each state election is administered
independently, but the anti-democratic tendencies
of the Republican Party have been clear for
a long time.
It's scaled up because Donald Trump knows
it's not thinks he knows.
And he's right that if he can keep disproportionately
Democrats from voting, including by blocking
vote by mail, he is in a much better position
to potentially defeat Joe Biden in November.
So what do we have to do?
Well, number one.
We've got to completely overwhelm the voting
booths in November.
And I hate that it's the only sure fire method.
But if we completely overwhelm the voting
booths and vote by mail, absentee ballots,
everything that ensures that we win, Trump
can only cheat so much.
And if we don't allow him to prevent people
from voting one way or another, that is very,
very important.
Now, secondly, we've got to keep pushing on
vote by mail, particularly in certain
states.
And I'm going to address that a little bit
more in the next segment.
But understand, if we overwhelm the voting
booths, he can't win.
We just need to do it.